الكهرباء مساله
وصلنا الحمد لله ان ما بقاش في تخفيف
للاحمال وده يعتبر اعجاز
لم تمر اربعه اشهر على هذا التصريح حتى
عادت الكهرباء للانقطاع في مصر مع العوده
لخطه تخفيف الاحمال
فما سبب الانتكاسه واين يكمن السبب الازمه
وهل فوجئ بها المسؤولون ام اساءوا تقديرها
منذ العام 2013 توسعت مصر في بناء محطات
توليد الكهرباء خوفا من عجز الانتاج وطمعا
في التحول الى مركز لتوزيع الطاقه في
المنطقه بلغ عدد المحطات في منتصف العام
69 محطه مجموع قدراتها
59,86 ميجا وات ويصل اقصى حمل الى
34,900 وهو اعلى مما تحتاجه مصر ويترك
فائضا يمثل
25% تقريبا من اجمالي طاقه المولده وهو ما
شجع الحكومه على تفعيل منظومه الربط
الكهربائي مع ليبيا والاردن والسودان وبحث
الربط مع السعوديه ودول الخليج مصر اذا لا
تعوجها المحطات ولا كفاءه الشبكه فاين
المشكله خلال
2022 استهلكت محطات توليد الكهرباء اكثر
من 34 الف طن من الوقود يمثل الغاز
الطبيعي تسعين في المئه منها تقريبا
الاعتماد على الغاز بدا منطقيا مع انخفاض
سعره وتوفره مع تعظم انتاج مصراب اكتشاف
حقل ظهور الذي يمثل وحده اربعين في المئه
من انتاج الغاز المصري
مثلا دلاع الحرب الروسيه على اوكرانيا
نقطه تحول في قطاع الطاقه عالميا اذ ادى
انقطاع امدادات الغاز الروسي الى اوروبا
الى ارتفاع اسعاره ما اغرى الحكومه
المصريه بالاتجاه الى تصديره لتوفير
العمله الاجنبيه في وقت يعاني فيه
الاقتصاد بالفعل من شح الدولار وتراكم
الالتزامات الخارجيه للدائنين تبع ذلك
التوجه الى قرارات تقشفيه حكوميه مع تخفيف
الاحمال جزئيا بقطع التيار عن بعض الشوارع
مع البدء في تحويل بعض المحطات للعمل
بالمازوت الارخص سعرا في شهر ابريل عام
ومع استقرار اسعار طاقه اصبح سعر المازوت
اعلى من الغاز الطبيعي لتبدا الحكومه
العوده لتشغيل المحطات بالغاز الطبيعي
لتقليل فاتوره استيراد المازوتي في ظل
الازمه الدول
لكن انتاج الغاز الطبيعي المصري كان يشهد
تراجعا مضطردا منذ العام 2021 وهو ما
عازته مؤسسه فيتش سوليوشنز الى انخفاض
انتاج حقل ظهر نتيجه تسرب المياه بسبب
التسرع ومحاوله زياده الانتاج عن الحد
المسموح به فنيا الحكومه المصريه النفث
وجود مشاكل تقنيه في الحقل المصري الاكبر
وقالت انه يعمل بكامل كفاءته لكنها لم
تفسر سببا انخفاض انتاجه بنحو الثلث من
متوسط انتاج يومي بنحو ثلاثه مليارات
ومئتين مليون قدم مكعب عام 2020 الى
مليارين و300 مليون قدم مكعب عام
2023 ولم تفسر ايضا سبب نقص امدادات
الوقود الى محطات الكهرباء في ظل تاكيد
رئيس الوزراء انه لا يصدر في اشهر الصيف
الصيف احنا بنوقف تصدير الغاز لان بيحصل
ان احنا بنزيد حجم استهلاكنا وبالتالي
احنا اللي بيحصل ان احنا بنوقف تصدير
الغاز بالكامل في فتره الصيف ماذا حدث اذا
في فصل الصيف بحسب رئيس الوزراء مصطفى
مدبولي فان السبب الازمه هو ارتفاع درجات
الحراره التي تؤثر على ضغط الغاز وكفاءه
المحطات بالاضافه الى تزايد الاستهلاك
بسبب اجهزه التبريد وهو ما خلق طلبا على
الوقود لم تكن الحكومه تتحسب له مدبولي
قال ان الازمه ستستمر ما لم تنخفض الحراره
عن 35 درجه مئويه الى اين تتجه الازمه
الحكومه استعرضت اجراءات عده لتخفيف
الاستهلاك منها اقامه مباريات كره القدم
نهارا رغم انتهاء الموسم كما اعلنت جداول
بمواعيد قطع الكهرباء عن محافظات
الجمهوريه التي ست منها المناطق الحيويه
والسياحيه بالاضافه الى وعد باستيراد
كميات من المازوت بنحو 250 الى 300 مليون
دولار لسد عجز الانتاج بانتظار انكسار
الموجه الحاره اجراءات الحكومه لم تتطرق
لحلول مستدامه او طويله الامد رغم
التقارير الامميه التي تؤكد استمرار
الاحترار العالمي وتفاقمه ما يعني ان فصول
الصيف القادمه ستكون اكثر سخونه وان
الحكومه المصريه بحاجه الى رؤيه اوسع
وحلول اعمق لطي صفحه ازمه الطاقه وانهاء
كابوس العدس
[موسيقى]